مشاهد هذه الصور من عسقلان قبل قليل
وننوه ايضا مشاهدينا الى هذا العاجل حيث
مصادر اذا للجزيره عن تعثر الوصول الى
اتفاق تهدئه في غزه
هذه صور اذا
لعسقلان قبل قليل بعيده انطلاقي رشقات
صاروخيه من القطاع باتجاهها
معنى الالم العسقلان التي وصلت اليها
صواريخ المقاومه الفلسطينيه مراسله
الجزيره الياس كرام يعني تصعيد لافه الياس
لصواريخ المقاومه على تمام الساعه التاسعه
بتوقيت غزه وفلسطين قياسا بما شاهدنا في
ساعات النهار كيف بدت لك الصوره على
الجانب الاخر
واضح بان الامور تتجه نحو مزيد من التصعيد
ومزيد من الرشقات الصاروخيه نحن نشير في
الساعه الاخيره ايمان الى اضرار جسيمه في
مباني في قلب حي سكني في مدينه عسقلان هذه
هذا الحي تعرض الى اصابه مباشره باحد
صواريخ المقاومه التي اطلقت باتجاه
المدينه في الساعه الاخيره وكانت رشقات
كثيفه يبدو ان القبه الحديديه فشلت في
اعتراض عدد منها وسقط بعضها في داخل مباني
في داخل حي سكني في مدينه عسقلان اضرار
جسيمه بحسب الانباء التي ترد من هناك
وايضا هنالك انباء تشير الى اصابات مباشره
ايضا واضرار في مباني في مدينه ازديرات
الواقعه الى الشمال الشرقي من قطاع غزه
هذه المدينه التي تعرضت ايضا في الساعات
الاخيره الى وابل كثيف من الني من جانب
المقاومه الفلسطينيه كانت في الساعه
الاخيره انباء تتحدث عن اصابه اسرائيل
بجروح خطيره لكن الاسعاف الاسرائيلي في
تحديثه الاخير يشير الى ان الاصابه هي
اصابه بحاله هلا لكن اضرار جسيمه واضرار
مباشره في عدد من المباني في مدينه
ازديروت هذا اليوم وايضا في مدينه عسقلان
هنالك اضرار ايضا واصابات مباشره في مدينه
في النقب الغربي وفي عده منازل ايضا في
المجمع
مجمع اشكول الواقع في النقب الغربي والذي
يضم عددا من البلدات والقرى التعاونيه
الاسرائيليه في منطقه وسط قطاع غزه
الاسعاف الاسرائيلي كما اشرت ايمان يقول
بان هنالك اصابات تم تسجيلها في الساعات
الاخيره لكنها ليست اصابات مباشره من
الصواريخ لكن هي اصابات في صفوف
الاسرائيليين الذين يغرعون على عجل الى
الملاجئ ويتعرضون لكسور وردود وردود
واصابات وينقلون ايضا على اثرها الى
المستشفى في مستشفى درزيلاي في عسقلان
الان هنالك تحديث يتحدث عن
ثمانيه عشر او سته عشر اصابه وصلت الى
مستشفى برزيلاي في مدينه عسقلان في هذا
الخبر العاجل ايمان 16 اصابه ثمانيه منها
هي اصابات بحالات هلا
وثماني اصابات اخرى
كانت ايضا في صفوف الاسرائيليين لكن نتيجه
وقوعهم او اصابتهم وهم يهرعون في حاله
الهلع الى الملاجئ نشير الى ان عسقلان
تعرضت
كثيف لحجم الاضرار التي لحقت بمدينه
عسقلان جراء الصواريخ التي انطلقت من غزه
قبل قليل اذا هذه هي ح جم الاضرار
نعم تفضل الياس تفضل
نعم نعم ايمان كنت تشير ايضا في بدايه هذه
النشره الى كثافه النيران التي اطلقتها
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وفي اتجاهات متعدده
قبل ان نظهر على الشاشه في تمام التاسعه
وكنت تلاحظين ايمان بان هنالك ارباك شديد
في عمليه اعتراض الصواريخ من جانب
المنظومه منظومه القبه الحديديه ربما كنت
تشاهدين بان عمليه الاعتراض تتم على
ارتفاعات مختلفه بمعنى عاليه ومتوسطه
وبعضها يكاد يكون اعتراضات قريبه جدا من
الارض وهذه الاعتراضات ربما الاخطر وبعض
في بعض الاحيان حتى صواريخ القبه الحديديه
ذاتها تصيب مباني شاهقه في المدن الكبرى
في عسقلان وفي في اسدود وهذا وقع وحدث في
مرات سابقه في المواجهات تحديدا في عام
2021 وهذا يدل على الخبره المقاومه
الفلسطينيه تتمتع فيها
بالتعامل مع منظومه القبه الحديديه رشقات
صاروخيه كثيفه ومتتاليه تؤدي الى صعوبه في
تلقيم واعاده تلقيم فوهات القبه الحديديه
من قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي ذلك ان هنالك
حاجه لاعاده تلقيم هذه المنظومات بمزيد من
صواريخ التنير ولكن عندما تطلق المقاومه
صواريخ بكثافه وبشكل متتالي يصعب ربما
اعاده تلقيم هذه المنظومه كما ان الصواريخ
التي تطلقها المقاومه هي عمليا في اتجاهات
متعدده تشتت وتربك القبه الحديديه وعلى
ارتفاعات متعدده مما يعني نشاهد بان
صواريخ التنير تكاد تلتقط وتصطاد هذه
الصواريخ على ارتفاعات منخفضه جدا من
الارض وفوق اسطح المنازل مما يسبب اضرارا
جسيمه في المباني وفي السيارات وفي
الممتلكات العامه وطبيعه الحال اسرائيل في
هذه المرحله لا تك عمليا عن كل الاضرار
التي تتعرض لها هذه المدن التي
توجه صوبها الصواريخ لكن بعد الانتهاء من
هذه الجوله دائما ما نسمع بان الدعاوى
التي تقدم للتعويض تبلغ تصل الى الاف
دعاوى التعويض وتقدر على الاقل بحسب
الجوله الاخيره في عام 2021
اصابه في مدينه عسقلان بعد تعرضها لدفعه
من الصواريخ اطلقت من غزه